hey guys so a ton of you have been
reaching out to tell me that you've been
either unsubscribed from our YouTube
channel or to let me know that you're no
longer seeing our videos in your feed
hopefully you're seeing this right now
but if you haven't seen any of our
videos lately I promise you we are not
on a break we're still releasing at
least one full interview per week and
usually it's more than that make sure
you're signed up for notifications
wherever you may watch the Rubin report
to check out our new content as its
released for YouTube viewers double
check to make sure that you're
subscribed in the first place and click
the bell icon by the subscribe button to
get alerts as videos are posted if
you're playing along on Facebook make
sure you've both followed and liked the
Reuben report and Dave Rubin or if
Twitter is your thing may God help you
give me a follow at Rubin report and
last but not least if you prefer to
listen via podcast the Reuben report is
available on an array of players
including Apple stitcher Spotify or just
subscribe to our RSS feed and whatever
app you prefer the link is in the
description right down below and of
course if you want to check out some
premium content in addition to our
regular interviews head over to
patreon.com slash Reuben report and sign
up to be a monthly supporter we built a
really incredible interactive community
over there that I'm truly proud of and
there's a ton of great perks and bonuses
at a variety of donation levels no
matter how you consume the Reuben report
my team and I thank you for your
continued support and we look forward to
bringing you even more exciting and
diverse content and conversation in the
very near future
[Music]
you